>> ♪ ♪
>> JOE BIDEN FEELING THE HIT
OVER THE UKRAINE SCANDAL
THREATENING TO DERAIL HIS
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
JOE AND HUNTER COULD BE FORCED
TO TESTIFY IN AN OFFICIAL SENATE
TRIAL.
AND LINDSEY GRAHAM IS OFFERING
RUDY GIULIANI THE CHANCE TO
TESTIFY BEFORE HIS COMMITTEE
ABOUT POTENTIAL BIDEN
WRONGDOING.
THAT'S JUST THE BEGINNING OF
SLEEPY JOE'S TROUBLES.
BIG MONEY DEMOCRAT DONORS WHO
ARE FRUSTRATED OVER HIS MANY
GAFFES AND HOW HE IS HANDLING
TRUMP'S ATTACKS.
BIDEN'S MAIN RESPONSE TO THE
UKRAINE CONTROVERSY IS RAGE.
>> HERE'S WHAT I KNOW.
I KNOW TRUMP DESERVES TO BE
INVESTIGATED.
YOU SHOULD BE ASKING HIM THE
QUESTIONS.
WHY IS HE ON THE PHONE WITH A
FOREIGN LEADER.
YOU SHOULD LOOK AT TRUMP.
HE KNOWS I WILL BEAT HIM LIKE A
DRUM.
>> IT'S NOT A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST.
I WON'T RESPOND TO THAT!
LET'S FOCUS ON THIS MAN!
WHAT HE IS DOING.
THAT NO PRESIDENT HAS EVER DONE.
>> JUST BREAKING, THE WHITE
HOUSE SENDING A LETTER TO HOUSE
DEMOCRATS DEMANDING THEY DROP
IMPEACHMENT CALLING IT INVALID
AND UNFAIR AND AN ATTEMPT TO
OVERTURN THE 2016 ELECTION AND
INFLUENCE 2020 AND SAYS THEY
WON'T COMPLY WITH THIS
IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" OVER THE
WEEKEND CAME OUT WITH A BIG
STORY ABOUT HOW BIDEN'S REACTION
WAS A CASE STUDY IN POLITICAL
INDECISION.
HE WAITED A WEEK OR TWO TO DO
ANYTHING.
AT THE END JUST WHY WOULD AT A
REPORTER AND PUT OUT AN OP-ED.
>> RIGHT.
THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN SAID YOU TOO
"NEW YORK TIMES"?
I CAN'T BELIEVE YOU ARE DOING
THIS TO ME.
THE QUOTE IN THE ARTICLE THAT I
THOUGHT WERE THE MOST TROUBLING
ARE THE ONES ANONYMOUS FROM THE
DONORS.
DONORS DON'T ALWAYS HAVE THE
BEST FEEL FOR WHAT NEEDS TO BE
HAPPEN ON A CAMPAIGN.
THEY WILL SAY YOU NEED TO BE
DOING SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
YOU DON'T SEE THIS KIND OF THING
FOR WARREN, MAYOR PETE.
EVEN HARRIS OR BOOKER WHO HASN'T
BEEN ABLE TO RAISE A LOT OF MON.
KLOBUCHAR.
YOU DON'T SEE BLIND QUOTES IN A
PAPER SAYING THEY ARE SCREWING
THIS UP.
THAT'S BECAUSE YOU HAVE DONORS
WHO HAVE FRIENDSHIPS WITH PEOPLE
IN THE MEDIA AND THEY WANT TO BE
CALLED UPON IN THE FUTURE.
THEY ARE TRYING TO SHOW THEIR
CARDS.
THEY ARE ABOUT TO TURN.
THEY OF PIVOT AWAY FROM HIM.
THAT'S WHAT I WOULD BE WORRIED
ABOUT IF I WERE BIDEN.
>> SOME HAVE PIVOTED AWAY.
HE DIDN'T HAVE THE FUND-RAISING
HE EXPECTED.
BIDEN SAID HE WANTS TO MEET
DONALD TRUMP OUTSIDE OF THE GYM
AND HE WILL KNOCK HIM OUT.
DONALD IS WAITING AND WHERE IS
JOE?
>> I SAID THIS LAST WEEK.
BIDEN'S COZY NEPOTISM RESONATES
MORE CLEARLY THAN TRUMP'S
INQUIRIES ABOUT IT.
IF BIDEN IS BEHOLDEN TO CHINA OR
UKRAINE, SHOULDN'T THE MEDIA
WELCOME THIS INQUIRY?
THEY SPENT 3 YEARS TALKING ABOUT
COLLUSION.
IN BETWEEN YOUR WRITING OF BOOKS
ABOUT RUSSIAN COLLUSION, MAYBE
YOU CAN LOOK INTO THIS.
YOU ARE STILL WORKING ON GETTING
YOUR ADVANCE FOR YOUR BOOK.
DO YOU KNOW WHO JOE BIDEN REMIND
ME OF.
YOU TALKED YESTERDAY ABOUT THE
THROWING STARS.
IN LONDON I WAS INVITEED TO PLAY
SOCCER WITH A BUNCH OF HIGH
SCHOOL KIDS.
I PLAYED BEFORE.
I FELT LIKE I COULD HANDLE IT.
I COULD PASS AND SCORE.
I MIGHT IMPRESS THEM.
THE MOST I SET FOOT ON THE FIELD
I WAS LIKE A TACKLING DUMMY IN
SUNGLASSES.
I WAS OUT OF MY LEAGUE.
THAT'S BIDEN NOW.
ON THE SIDELINES HE BEING
COMPETE AND PLAY.
NOW IN THE GAME HE CAN'T KEEP
UP.
WHEN YOU WALK AROUND HIM YOU
WANT TO TIGHTEN EVERY BOLT WITH
AN ALLEN WRENCH.
I THINK HE WILL BE OUT.
>> HE IS ON THE DECLINE.
JUAN, THIS LETTER THAT JUST CAME
OUT CALLING THE WHOLE THING
ILLEGITIMATE AND SAYING IT'S
RIGGED AGAINST THE PRESIDENT AND
THE REPUBLICANS AND ADAM SCHIFF
IS LEADING IT.
HE CAN'T BE TRUSTED.
AND THROWS DOWN THE GAUNTLET
SAYING PUT UP OR SHUT UP TO THE
DEMOCRATS.
>> YOU CAN THROW THAT LETTER IN
THE TRASH.
>> THE PRESIDENT.
>> A STABLE GENIUS.
>> IT'S ADDRESSED TO THE
DEMOCRATS.
I THINK IT'S INTENDED FOR
REPUBLICANS.
I THINK THE BIDEN STORY, BEFORE
I COME BACK TO THE LETTER, I
THINK IT'S VERY INTERESTING THAT
IN POLLS OUT TODAY FOR THE FIRST
TIME YOU SEE ELIZABETH WARREN AS
THE NUMBER 1 DEMOCRAT IN THE
POLL.
SHE AT 29 AND JOE BIDEN AT 26.
NOW SHE IS WITHIN THE MARGIN OF
ERROR.
AND 2% AHEAD OF JOE BIDEN.
THAT'S MORE INTERESTING.
LET ME GO FURTHER ON THAT.
HER GAIN IS NOT COMING OUT OF
JOE BIDEN.
HER GAIN IS COMING OUT OF PEOPLE
LIKE KAMALA HARRIS AND PETE
BUTTIGIEG.
THEY ARE GOING DOWN.
WE HAVE A 3 PERSON RACE, BIDEN,
WARERN AND BERNIE SANDERS WHO
HAD A HEART ATTACK.
WE WILL SEE IF HE CAN GET HIS
ENERGY UP.
BIDEN MIGHT NOT BE DOING GREAT.
THE DONORS ARE ALWAYS NERVOUS
AND THEY WANT BIDEN TO BE MORE
COMBATIVE AND GO AFTER TRUMP IN
A VICIOUS WAY AND BIDEN IS NOT
THAT GUY.
>> IF SOMEONE WAS GOING AFTER
YOUR INTEGRITY AND YOUR FAMILY
YOU MIGHT THROW A FEW PUNCHES
BUT WAITING FOR THE MEDIA TO
DEFENDER HIM.
>> HE IS COMBATIVE.
IN THE WRONG WAY.
HE LOOKS LIKE HE'S ALREADY LOST.
HE IS VERY DEFENSIVE.
HE IS WORRIED ABOUT HIS SON'S
BUSINESS DEALINGS AND ABOUT
ELIZABETH WARREN.
THE PROBLEM IS ALL OF THE WORRY
SHOWS IN EVERY INTERACTION HE
HAS.
WHEN HE GETS ON THE DEBATE STAGE
HE DOESN'T LOOK CONFIDENT OR IN
CONTROL.
MANY PEOPLE CAN'T CITE WHAT JOE
BIDEN WOULD DO AS PRESIDENT.
HE IS UNAVAILABLE TO PRIORITYIZE
HIS STANDS ON THE ISSUES.
ONCE THE OP-ED IN THE
"WASHINGTON POST" CAME OUT I
SAID THIS GUY DOESN'T KNOW HOW
TO CREATE A GRASSROOTS MOVEMENT.
HE IS BACK IN A POLITICAL TIME
WHEN YOU WOULD HAND OVER TALKING
POINTS TO THE "WASHINGTON POST"
AND SELL YOURSELF THIS WAY.
THAT'S NOT HOW IT GOES ANYWHERE.
YOU ARE GOING AGAINST WARREN AND
SANDERS WHO HAVE THAT ENERGY AND
CAN TAP INTO THE CROWD.
HE IS LOST.
YOU HAVE DONORS ARE LOOKING AT
HIM AND SAYING THIS GUY IS NOT
ABLE TO DEFEND THIS ISSUE WITH
UKRAINE AND NOT ABLE TO DEFEND
HIMSELF ON THE STAGE.
WHERE WILL HE SHINE THAT WILL
ENABLE US FEEL CONFIDENT TO HAND
OVER MONEY?
>> WHERE IS BARACK OBAMA?
THERE HAVE BEEN ACCUSATIONS THAT
BARACK OBAMA'S VICE-PRESIDENT IS
INVOLVED WITH VERY, VERY SKETCHY
STUFF OVERSEAS RIGHT UNDER HIS
NOSE.
HE HASN'T SAID ONE WORD.
I WONDER IF ME WILL GO TO.
>> THE NEW YORKER WRITES THIS
PIECE IN JULY.
IT WAS VERY LONG ABOUT HUNTER
BIDEN.
ALL THE ALLEGATIONS ARE LAID OUT
AND HUNTER BIDEN DOES AN
INTERVIEW TO DEFEND HIMSELF
THERE.
RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION THIS HUGE
FEATURE PIECE SHOWS UP IN THE
NEW YORKER AND NO ONE BROUGHT IT
UP.
THE ONLY TIME IT GOT ATTENTION
WAS WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP BROUGHT
IT UP ON THE CALL.
THAT'S WHEN THE MEDIA TOOK
ACTION.
THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN DID NOT HAVE
SOMETHING READY KNOWING THAT NEW
YORKER PIECE WAS COMING OUT.
>> THE FAILURE OF DEMOCRATS TO
KNOW HOW TO DEAL WITH THIS KIND
OF ONSLAUGHT COMES FROM THE
CONSPIRACY CROWD ON THE RIGHT.
>> THEY SHOULD LOOK AT
THEMSELVES.
I FEEL BAD FOR JOE BUT I DON'T.
THEY MADE THEIR BED.
THE MEDIA AND THE DEMOCRATS
ATTEMPTED TO UNDO THE ELECTION
IN THE 2016.
NOW THE GOO WILL SUCK HIM IN.
YOU WILL HAVE ELIZABETH WARREN
WHO USED NATIVE-AMERICANS AND
HER OWN CHILD TO PORTRAY HERSELF